foreign
when I was a kid I fell off of this
house on our construction and and I fell
12 feet and it seemed to take a long
time and I got really interested in this
issue of does time run in slow motion
when you're in fear for your life I mean
I got interested in that question once I
became a neuroscientist and had grown up
and so I did this experiment I think you
know about this where I dropped people
from 150 foot tall tower in free fall
falling backwards they're caught in a
net below and I measured the speed of
their perception as they're falling
because everybody is it has this
experience or knows someone at this
experience where they get in a car
accident things seem to run in slow
motion and they can report all these
details of what happened anyway long
story short it turns out that the whole
thing is a trick of memory people don't
actually perceive faster during a scary
event it's just that they laid down more
memory so when they read this back out
they say what just happened just
happened it seems like they've got much
more memory than they would in normal
circumstances
so they say you know I watched the hood
crumple in the rearview mirror fall off
and the expression on the other guy's
face and then okay anyway that got me
thinking about this issue about how we
lay down memory and it turns out that
you know we touched on memory a while
ago but most things in your life you do
not remember you know the number of
cracks in the sidewalk and who is
wearing what and what was on the menu on
the wall that like we just don't
remember almost everything
because the job of memory is to write
down stuff that matters that's
emotionally Salient or informationally
relevant you're just writing this tiny
fraction but anyway when you're
estimating how long it's been since some
event
the way you estimate that is by drawing
on the footage that you have saying oh
well see this happens okay so that must
have been two months since I saw my
friend or it must have been another two
years since I saw this other person that
kind of thing so anyway
this was a whole bunch of research in my
lab over the course of a decade that
came together but the point is
if you're laying down richer memories
you won't necessarily live longer but
you will make it seem as though you've
lived longer because when you're asking
what just happened or how long has it
been you've got more data more footage
to draw on and and of course we all know
this feeling when you go on
some super exciting trip on the weekend
and you come back and you're back on a
Monday you think oh my gosh it's been
forever since it was Friday there's so
many things that happen but if you just
have a normal weekend you think oh my
gosh it's Monday it was just Friday
there's nothing to write down and so you
don't feel that that there was much
duration that happened there
so this is why I think one of the most
important things in life is about
seeking novelty and always putting
yourself in new situations such that
you're laying down dense Memories the
analogy last thing I'll say on this is
when you get to the end of a childhood
summer it seems that the summer lasted
forever and it's because everything is
new so you're writing stuff down in your
memory but when you're older you've seen
it all before and and you get to the end
of a summer and you think wow I can't
believe it's over already I don't really
remember it at all it seems as though
the summer didn't last long
is it fair to
then take from that the key Criterion
for Rich memory as novelty doing new
things exactly
and you know by the way this is one of
the tiny Silver Linings to the pandemic
which otherwise sucked but the one
interesting part from the point of view
of brain plasticity was that it knocked
all of us off our hamster wheels and we
were finding that the world wasn't what
we expected it was just unbelievable
like if we had talked in 2019 and said
hey could this ever happen we say that's
a great sci-fi story but there's no way
that it would be that weird but it was
actually that weird and we all locked
ourselves in our houses for ten thousand
years and so this is the kind of thing
you know when you go to the store and
there's no toilet paper there on the
shelves it takes your internal model and
it totally says whoa I didn't even know
that could happen you start thinking
about Supply chains you start thinking
about how the world Works you're
thinking about wait is is the barber
shop going to be open can I get a
haircut during pandemic is this coffee
shop going to be open I mean it just
forced us to think about the world
completely new and I think if 2019 had
continued and it has just been the same
old world we'd actually be
less smart in a sense because our our
internal models just would have never
gotten challenged in that way
[Music]
here's my idiophysis which is an idiotic
hypothesis I think that I come up with
these a lot but I think that we might
actually see a tiny decline in dementia
some decades from now
just because we had this opportunity in
the middle of our Lives to actually kind
of restructure everything and have to
rethink everything going on